one area I feel like engines really
struggle with is evaluating material
imbalances for example what if one side
just up a pond is that plus one is it
more is it less and I feel like an
engine like stock fish often likes the
material much more than it should also
control of squares when you see an
opening like the Kings Indian defense it
tend to really like White's position
because white has a stronger center and
I think underestimates blacks counter
play in the lines which is that well
let's look at this game where it was a
Leningrad Dutch in opening that I really
don't like and so d4 f5 and well maybe I
should start liking it because alpha
zero plays it and wins with it
so what do I know about chess Knight f3
and I have six and okay this follows a
very natural plan of action both sides
developing castling and White has the
better control of the center because of
these nice pawns on c4 and d4 right
those are controlling the central
squares
you know d5c v e5 these kind of squares
are all under control
black to its credit has control over in
the e4 square and can play h6g 528
between h5 right
by having the pawn on f5 rather than f7
it opens up that diagonal for the Queen
to jump over the Kings side and launch
an attack that will come in handy in
this game so d6 okay all these moves are
pretty normal
Queen b3 keeping the bishop honest on
the CA squared the covered b7 also
threatening at some point c5 check to
open up a discover in the King all these
moves make perfect sense h6 look at the
evaluation bar it's it jumped out to
plus one point three two now it goes
back down to plus 0.8 three and that's
because it's looking at more applying to
see the position more deeply and this is
a chess calm server engine which is the
stock fish stock explained with the
white pieces alpha zero does not look at
chess the same way it's not looking at
my you know five tenths of a pawn better
my 5/10 on worse so I think that
actually proves to be a huge advantage
when playing the traditional and
so white does everything normally to
gain space see if I would check do not
play this move pawn to d5 because if you
play this move d6 to d5 you have huge
trouble after Bishop f4 the rooks under
attack if your rook moves you lose the
b7 pawn this Knight has the e5 square to
use as well so everything is sort of
favoring white in a position like this
you definitely don't want to play d5 so
the King runs away Knight a 4 and what I
say about squares right currently is b6
square it looks weak it would become an
outpost for the white knight no black
pawn can kick it out whereas because
White's setup is as such there are no
outpost for blacks pieces so Brooke 8 I
love this move arcade defending this
pawn a5 so that the Queen can goat on
his King side journey really good move
so all this stuff is following the plans
the themes that I discussed before
clearly black trying to get that Queen
over there to the Kings side white on
the other hand would love to team up on
this pawn on a5 which is why 92 for h5
and Bishop f3 or time so Bishop on f3 it
attacks the Queen
it makes Knight g4 a little harder to
play because then just Knight back to f1
the nice pin to the Queen not exactly
the most comfortable situation for black
but you find g4 is also in a way a
concession because the plane is from g4
it means I'm not gonna get f4 in of
course that even with my King off the
age 7 square before playing f4 but
that's one of the main ideas is breaking
open the Kings side and g4 looks like it
closes the King side but after Bishop e2
King h8 a very good move getting the
King off that diagonal with the Queen
sort of lurking and Knight c4 so look at
the evaluation bar plus point 9 1 at the
moment and that's now jumped over +1 and
the point is that this pawn on a5 is
going to
it's gonna be lost white is threatening
the d6 pawn and the a5 pawn the same
time and so the engine is being stopped
and who loves this position but not so
fast because 94 makes perfect sense
threatening to come to g5 and then once
it gets to g5 you know came over to age
3 or to f3
it's very dangerous so h4 just stops the
knight coming in g5 right because if you
go to g5 we'll just take you you can't
take my pawn on Bassam because you lose
your queen on each five so there's looks
like a very good move for white but this
is one of pausing because it's just so
nice Knight g5 anyway alpha zero must
have recognized a while back that this
sacrifice would give it the upper hand
yes you're giving up a knight for one
pawn and it says at the current moment
plus 1.16 in White's favor but that's
misleading because after pawn takes d5
pawn takes g5 and then evaluation just
sneaking up to almost 3 and it's coming
back down quickly to one point to wait
and look at that it's shrinking and
shrinking and all of a sudden you see
that black is the one who is actually
picking up steam here has an
advantageous position because blacks
plan is simple rook to f6 rook to h6
Queen in for checkmate if that one
doesn't work maybe I can go f4 and just
break open the F file so white tries to
play f3 saying that I've now opened up
the second-ranked for some defense I can
even put my rook on d2 and swing it to
the H file and after g f3 Bishop f1 f4
it's exactly what stockfish did live
rook to d2 threatening rook h2 winning
that Queen right the Queen will be
pinned but the tactics
concretely favored black here alpha zero
just has a perfect position because
after pawn takes c3 if you play rook
edge to now f2 check comes your King has
to go over and he doesn't matter where
you go I'm sacking my queen and it looks
like all as well but then rook up six
comes into play and rook h6 check is
just leading to a mate because your king
only has one square and
jeetu my bishop will always be able to
go to the age 3 square with check I
might as well as for my room to f8 first
and blacks King he's just getting a
swarm right all of CA White's Kings nice
warm blacks pieces are all they're
threatening to checkmate it and not to
mention that there is this bishop
hanging the moment's notice to take on a
one so instead after pawn takes c3 1983
was played go up the same exact idea
right rook h2 is still a deadly pin
winning the Queen on h5
but after 93 rook age - you don't want
to take this Queen on c2 because if you
do that rogue age 5 comes check the King
has to move the g8 and then you lose
your knight on c2 and black still is
compensation but white is doing well in
a position like this so don't be fooled
and this move Bishop age 3 another
wonderful shot and look at the
evaluation up to almost 0.94 black okay
just came back down a little bit but
stockfish not certain of itself here and
why Bishop h3 is so nice is after rook
83 USAC this Queen on the h3 square
you've got a rook for the bishop and you
gave and let's do a material account
when we get to the end of this here we
see that black has two rooks and seven
pounds White has a rook two minor pieces
and four three pawns in a rook for two
minor pieces that is more than enough
for the black cider so alpha zero has
achieved a much better position but
converting it to win may not be so easy
and let's see how this happens black
playing normally okay attacking the
bishop the rook comes to defense and now
rook to F face you can't take on f3
because if you take on a3 with the rook
you lose your bishop on e6 and now alpha
zero initiates a very forcing sequence
97 attacking the rook on f8 trying to
kick it off the f5 so you can take the
pawn in up three but look at this rook
gauge to check King f1 and rookie to
offering the exchange of rooks even at
the cost of a pawn is great for black
because you still have two pawns working
two pawns for the two minor pieces
and now white cannot protect the
remaining pawns you needed that rook on
the second rank defending the a2 pond
now this work is coming down very
quickly and well there's just no defense
or that side of the board
so rook h6 d5 and that's good because
now black has a clear two on none
majority in the center and what alpha
zero ends up doing is forcing stockfish
backward the bishop d1 okay you can take
this pawn a2 but instead King e7
attacking the knight on d7 and now king
of six so the king is just coming into
the action and that's what you need you
need some backup
you can't just play with a roving rook
you need the cane to come in to help the
pawns advance and so what alpha zero
does is give up both the b-pawn and the
jeep on here so p7 hangs with check but
okay King to b6 and now feel free to
take this Jeep on because once you take
g4 which you should because my pawn is
also just about to push to g3 you take
it but now b3 falls and black spawns are
unopposed the C pawn and D pawn with the
help of the king and the support of the
Brooke are just pushing through so in
fact the resignation occurred right here
because it just completely losing if you
go Knight f4 yeah you're keeping your
knight on the board but after King this
c5 this King comes to b4 and both of
these pawns will start marching towards
promotion so a phenomenal showing but
alpha zero understanding that well you
don't think in center pawns with the
deepmind creation instead you think in
ideas and very concretely and I think
that stockfish really didn't appreciate
just how beautiful this option was
because it looked like and just to show
that position again here that it looked
like white was stopping blacks the idea
was 90 G five right h4 is played
expressly to stop it right that is why
h4 happens but still 95 occurred and
once the H file was open white has to do
somethings that boy game made it and of
course black was able to
take full advantage again the engine
still shows that stocks which is better
we prove that's not the case so a great
performance by alpha zero and a very
deserving victory in this match